les municipalités ne savent pas
éradiquer les points de Deal ne peuvent
lutter contre l'insécurité rechigne à
appliquer la loi la justice l'école
étant de secteur régaliens vont mal en
revanche quand il s'agit de faire de la
com à dessous quand il s'agit
d'apparaître en col roulé ou en doudoune
d'obliger les Français à porter le
masque ou d'interdire les terrasses
chauffées hommes et femmes politiques
bandent les muscles alors tout ce bordel
ambiance il y en a une qui avait la
banane c'est la première ministre
Elisabeth borne qui s'est tapait des
bars dans l'hémicycle le problème
c'était pas le bon timing avec les
propos qui étaient en train d'être
abordés madame la Première ministre ceux
qui ont froid ne portent pas de col
roulés ceux qui ont froid accumulent les
couches de vêtements et de couverture
c'est pas le bon
timings
ces moments de liesse et de communion
devant un écran géant comme ici en 2018
n'auront pas lieu Paris Lille Strasbourg
Bordeaux ou encore Marseille ne
diffusons pas les matchs en public du
prochain Mondial au Qatar un boycott
motivé par plusieurs raisons tout
d'abord l'aspect économique un
dispositif comme celui-ci coûte près de
200000 € pour un tel événement et dans
le contexte actuel les municipalités
doivent économiser pour la ville de
Paris l'événement organisé par le Qatar
ne répond pas aux enjeux écologiques les
conditions environnementales notamment
et sociales nous questionnent sur
l'événement et ce n'est pas le modèle
que l'on souhaite promouvoir de grands
événements à Paris écoutez l'adjoint
écolo Dani dalgo se justifier les avions
qui vont apporter apporter les les
visiteurs dans les stades qui sont des
stades d'ailleurs climatisés ça en fait
on en veut plus le problème c'est que la
Ville de Paris chouchoute le Qatar
depuis des années le Qatar propriétaire
du PSG DOA Film Institute a été financé
qatari donc forcément d'une dizaine de
films lors du dernier Festival de Cannes
Vincent Lindon qui a fait une sortie
récente sur la coupe du monde de foot
été le président du jury du Festival de
Cannes visiblement là ça ne l'a pas gêné
à ce moment-là peut-être pas au courant
mais peut-être que ces gens-là
finalement ne sont au courant de rien ce
qu'il n'y a pas un problème entre votre
prise de position et le fait que le PSG
est pignon sur rue à Paris bah non voilà
c'est ce qui s'appelle une indignation
sélective peut-être qu'il soit un peu
bête
ne réfléchissent pas à tout mais c'est
le propre d'un Tartuffe vous savez que
la pièce de Molière c'était Tartuffe ou
l'imposteur
Andrieu alors là on s'est un peu égaré
parce qu'on parle du Paris Saint-Germain
[Applaudissements]
je vous adore les conservateurs vous
êtes tellement prévisibles ça fait
plaisir pourquoi voter cette potion de
rejet je ne comprends pas mon souffle
n'importe quel citoyen peut-il diriger
un pays la politique est-elle un métier
une élection est-elle un concours de
cuisine de gâteau comme un autre ce sont
toutes les questions que posent donc ce
nouveau programme britannique qui est
diffusé sur la chaîne Channel fort il
s'appelle make me Prime Minister faite
de moi le premier ministre ou un premier
ministre c'est donc une émission de
téléréalité
depuis plusieurs semaines on loue la
vertu de celui qui reconnaît des faits
de violence conjugales
[Applaudissements]
à la parole ce sont donc 12 sujets
britanniques ordinaires en tout cas
supposer mon ordinaire qui doivent
démontrer pourquoi et comment il ferait
un premier ministre valable c'est une
mission qui ressemble parfois un banal
entretien d'embauche on va voir une
pastille dans laquelle il répondent à
une question très simple quelle est la
chose la plus surprenante chez moi chez
eux on regarde
[Musique]
une conseillère municipale sur le fait
qu'elle ferait pipi dans sa culotte je
redis votre terme c'est infantilisant et
c'est rabaissant
voilà ça se passe comme ça tous les
conseils municipaux j'ai l'impression
quand même hein
s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
donc je prononce un rappel à l'ordre
avec inscription procès-verbal et nous
pouvons on a félicité
ça va être long pour le journaliste de
Vienne des pendent compte tenu de l'état
de la politique britannique il n'est pas
sûr que le format téléréalité pour
choisir le prochain Premier ministre
soit une si mauvaise idée